I have seven words for you go ahead what
is it gooble gobble gooble gobble uh-huh
one of us go on yes okay ah okay guys
now I understood the last three words oh
yeah do you know the reference to that
no I have no idea what that I don't know
the actual name of the film but it's
basically like a bunch of circus freaks
okay and a woman sits down with them and
they go gooble gobble gooble gobble one
of us one of us look at this video oh my
god no but is relevant to what what
we're talking about okay yeah so you may
have seen this is where all of these
people bro this is praying look at this
let me I'm gonna play this for you guys
and and you're gonna be unhappy that I
did but it's important that you hear it
so I hope you're ready for violence
[Music]
and to everything in my powers and in my
community I will love my black neighbors
the same as my white ones about you know
our our neighbors are black and they're
so nice and you know what my other
neighbors
they're not and they're also nice III
have friends that are all sorts of races
and they're they're all nice people like
I just don't he could have just spoke
all these words and everyone been like
word the right when I bring up is what
you just watched was a cult building
exercise sounds not I'm not exaggerating
nice literally what many cults will do
to reinforce ideas is to make you repeat
it so I I grew up with a lot of hacker
friends I used to program some stuff and
I would make little video games very
very minor but ultimately got more into
the social engineering side of hack the
hacker community Inca which is they call
human hacking I ultimately ended up
working for nonprofits where I would hey
come over here and sign up for
Greenpeace because understanding how the
human mind works I was one of the best
in the nation for numerous nonprofits
signing up new members okay
ultimately quit because I realized they
were lying about so much like so much of
the stuff is so evil and I thought I was
gonna do good right but I see this stuff
and getting someone to repeat something
is an anchoring technique it's like you
make them believe it by saying it yeah
okay even if you tell them like repeat
after me
I said you know X Y & Z it anchors it
you know it really helps reinforce that
these are all white people
worst of all they're all people who are
white who are like supposedly
anti-racist
yeah the reason I bring this up in the
context of what we're just talking about
before is that these people aren't
impossible to talk to because they've
been indoctrinated and they you you
can't really break them out I guess I
guess it's where the red pill mean kind
of makes sense yeah you know you wake up
to reality because you're one of these
people sitting there with your listen
man I sent this video to my friends
mm-hmm and I was like with no comment I
just here's the video yeah and I got
crazy defense of it
no no they're just they're just you know
it's the people's Mike you know you're
the people's Mike is where you say
something they respond that way everyone
can hear it right because everyone says
it and I'm like no that's when you're
giving out information this is like
describing internal action mm-hmm oh
well I mean you know tons of groups do
this and I'm like no this is a bunch of
people that already believe all this
stuff right so them sitting in a circle
telling each other how not racist they
are who is that helping you you know
it's like it's being spread around and
now everyone's like wow that's a call
that's very culty I know how they did it
or the the blackout thing on you you
know yesterday's Instagram you know that
it's like well everyone who follows
everybody already it's already the
circles the circles are already kind of
closed so they're all just showing each
other how virtuous they are yeah like
look at this look how anti-racist I am
one of us one of us yeah gooble gobble
gooble gobble seeing I was i my eyes
were rolling so hard when I saw all of
the blackout squares yeah that I swear I
could have generated a ton of
electricity if I hooked it up to a cable
spinning like crazy
you meant hooked it up to the beanie yes
I'm scrolling through and I'm like mmm
these people are all morons you know
that you posted it I think the Ralph
Wiggum one oh yeah that's the best one
I'm helping I know I saw and so I posted
this I'm not joining your cult and I
sent it to some friends and they were
like trying to defend it and I and I was
like just stop just stop you know I know
you know yeah you don't want to let it
go you don't want to admit it just stop
some people though my friends they were
like whoa what's going on yeah and I was
like you ever stop and think twice about
what you're posting and they're like I
don't know man cuz some people are just
sitting there and they see their friend
do it they do it I don't know I'm just
trying to fit in yeah yeah into the
crowd well so the reason I brought this
up is because when I try talking to
these people you mentioned we're
mentioning like Schrodinger's POC and
stuff like I was talking to a friend and
I and and they're defending all of this
stuff and so I sent him an article where
antiva threatened to burn
to theater okay for an event I was
organizing all right over last year the
headliner was Darrell Davis the famous
black jazz musician who D radicalizes
white supremacists he did a lot to write
however 200 that's amazing stories are
amazing but you know what's crazy is
he's a regular guy
yeah and that's his that's his thing
like he one of the stories he told was
that he met a white supremacist and it
turns out he was a white supremacist was
a big rock and roll fan and he has a
jazz musician had access to like some
famous car or something cool and he was
like you want to see the car and the guy
was like what and he's like yeah I can I
can bring I can show you the actual car
I camera the exact story and also this
white supremacist had like this this
like snap in his mind where he was like
this guy's cool yeah like he's giving me
like this a dream come true you like the
same things I do I didn't think that was
possible when you have a different color
skin yeah yeah but so here I'm talking
about it I send them the article okay
and I said because you know they've been
talking about an tyfa and trump and it's
like exaggerating all the stuff and i
said well here's happened to me and
instead of saying damn bro i'm sorry
that happened to you like what was it
all about there's a friend of mine you
know what she said to me but why didn't
you invite more black people are you
serious yeah and I was like what what
burn down the theater where I spend an
event on why are you asking me to
justify what I did or didn't do I was
like your victim blaming you tell her
that yeah it doesn't matter I don't care
for the idea it's just like I don't
understand how it is that what I tell
you that white people okay mm-hmm I
don't care that they're white but it is
part of like what you believe threaten
to burn a theater to the ground because
they didn't want it was put the event
was put in by a Jewish man okay an
immigrant a Mexican man and a Korean
white mixed-race person all of us yeah
like there's no like white blue
blue-eyed blonde-haired person
organizing this right and it was white
people threatening it and their first
reaction is justify why you did wrong
and I was like this is crazy our
headline
there was a black man yeah but there
should have been more I'm like it was
like disproportionately people of color
even organizing people yeah and the
event was called ending it was called
like ending violence racism and
authoritarianism okay and they
threatened to burn theater down
mind-blowing I was like we literally
tried putting an event where we're gonna
bring you know conservative figures
libertarian figures even progressives to
sit down and talk about these issues
that's it though they the left doesn't
want us together
these extremists okay the far left right
the gooble gobble people are Native
gobble no no no right the Google Google
blah blah they're not paying attention
at all yeah yeah so they only get their
cues from their priests both of their
new birth oh it's funny that you
mentioned that because I was actually
listening to them and it reminded me a
lot some people really aren't gonna like
this but it actually reminded me a lot
of being in church because when you have
a liturgy the pastor reads and then the
congregation repeats back so you'll read
it a lot read along in your bulletin or
in your hymnal and you you communicate
with each other that way and that is
exactly what that sounds like to me do
they know that they've adopted a
religion that's white or a cult yeah I
mean what is the difference religions
I mean being religion is a form of a
cult what it's I mean it's it's fine
line I guess fine lines and and there's
there's a scale for sure okay
but they're the reason I say this is a
cult another religion is of course cults
try to use the essence of religion yeah
but because it's worked forever
let's let's talk about the Abrahamic
religions they actually got books they
got rules they have priests who try to
their best to interpret and they're it's
not perfect it's not perfect at all but
for the most part you could actually
look at the Ten Commandments and be like
I have a list of things you're not
supposed to do and I see why and you
look at these people they have no rules
there's literally nothing you can do and
that's why I say it's a cult because all
you can do is adhere to the power
structure and those who say they're in
charge now of course that's true for
many religions there are people who
exploit religions but I look at someone
like Chris Pratt apparently is like a
legit Boy Scout really does walk
walk and he lives like a you know good
Christian and all its stuff okay and
there are people that they're good and
bad people no matter what so when I
agree with them I I grew up Catholic for
the first you know I think I sixth-grade
was the first grade I left Catholic
school and went to public school yeah
and there's just people men it's there's
some people who try to live right and
and do good by what their teachings are
and there are some people who pretend to
and exploit it the problem with this is
it's a bunch of people not paying
attention and a bunch of people
exploiting it there are some people who
aren't paying attention don't study
don't read anything they're not telling
you you know we want to do right by
these people for these reasons I believe
the term is sheeple yeah that's a good
term they're the ones watching
mainstream media believing everything
that it says oh that's what's going on
Wow I believe everything it's not even
it's not even so much that I think it's
that they know who their priests are and
as long as they heard it from them
they'll stick to it and a lot of their
priests are brands and marketing
companies and weird things like that
good point so so so here's where I would
separate the two because I gotta admit
I'm no fan of organized religion I'm not
practicing I'm not part of it I've my
own you know spiritual beliefs or
whatever saying but this is exploitation
for political power yep which we've seen
in the past from religions and so maybe
we could argue this is the emergence of
something which will eventually become
you know a hard book that you must you
know follow by at the time being it's
ago I just you know I remember talking
to some early some friends who weren't
pay attention and I said what they're
doing is cult-like behavior and they no
no no and then like a year later thought
you were right oh yeah that's a cult
that's pretty cool t they go around
beating people not all of them the armed
the armed idea ideologues of the group
and you could argue the same thing about
religion okay go for it you want to
argue the same about religion bro that
means you are all the things you're
complaining about so if you want to
argue that that's fine but the point I
was getting at in the beginning when I
brought this up was that trying to talk
to somebody to explain to them what's
really going on in the world they've
their blinders are on completely just
shut out from everything yeah I got here
and you were like take those blinders
off Adam I was like
oh now I see everything I don't even
think it was really I know I'm just
jokin now there are some people I know
who like you know man some of my friends
who have gone off the rails man so hard
to see you dude I know you told me
certain what we did we did some segments
about it yeah but there there are some
people I see them posting and it's like
the people these are people it's like
the gooble gobble people I think are the
reason I say that is because they're
they're not thinking about what they're
doing what they're following why they're
following it they just like being a part
of the winning team I guess it's a mob
mentality really it's all it is so when
you try to talk to them and say like
here's a piece of evidence their brain
shatters you know it's like all of a
sudden this thing they that made them
feel good and welcomed and accepted is
busted is broken they get angry about it
it's it's very very religious it very us
it really is and I'll tell you the one
big difference we can argue everything
about historical religions with actual
texts and history and everything and
wise that's probably not still a good
enough argument but I'll tell you this
if you are a Christian if you are a
Muslim if you are Jewish if you are I
don't know Confucian and you were
violent and trying to force your
ideology on other people we got problems
agreed if you are any one of those
religions and you want to Chile have a
conversation about it not over yeah man
I had somebody knock on the door uh this
is really funny it was a group of I
think it was Java's witnesses yeah no I
think it was it was they wear the suits
no no his little girls I don't know I
don't know what religion it was huh but
I it was like teenage girls maybe like
14 or 15 knocked on the door and I saw
outside on my street a bunch of people
with Bibles and I'm like okay what is
this and they asked me if I had time to
talk about you know our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ wasn't about Jesus it
wasn't so I just unfortunately and I
said a little bit and they asked me if I
was Christian or anything I said I
wasn't and to be honest I didn't want to
waste their time because I'm not
interested but I will pass along a
compliment that one of the most
important tenets of our constitutional
dem
Republic be very specific because I know
people get you know variant freedom of
religion no no it's uh the presumption
of innocence is a foundation of our
country and it's rooted in the story of
I believe it's Adam and Gomorrah and I
don't know it's been a while but you
know this probably by than I do about if
there's about one practice person that
will spare this idiot right yeah well
where's that story tell story so with
Sodom and Gomorrah what was basically
done is the number of men who needed to
be righteous for the city be saved was
negotiated from a high number to a very
very very low number and if you know
anything about the story there is not
even that number of good people in the
city so yes so the city's got per the
gist of the story was basically you know
God's all like i'ma blow this place up
and the dudes like but what if there's
like 1500 good people and it was like
okay well there's 100 I won't do it well
what if there was 50 good people guys
like okay 450 I wouldn't and eventual
goes down to one if there's one innocent
person I will not destroy it and then
like I guess it was like the good people
got saved or something so they fled the
city yeah and then God was like and I
think it was 10 I don't think we just
want it okay okay but it's very very few
but yeah so so in that regard think
about that story and how we you know
from that you have the story of the
righteous people must be saved you
cannot even kill like this is there's a
whole city that it needs to be punished
and full of sin but if there's one
innocent person you can't do it we got
black stones formulation is better that
ten guilty persons escape than one
innocent sufferer we got Ben Franklin
taking it up saying a hundred guilty
persons escape than one innocent
sufferer and I stand here proud as those
you know those ideas have passed through
our legal system and need to be
protected at all cost
and it's got a story in the Bible so I
look at that and I'm like those are good
things that protect the innocent you
look at what these people are doing and
they're chanting gooble gobble over and
over again and there's nothing going on
in those ideas but also a really
important point someone mentioned in the
in the comments which really you know
draws that line between the two is
separation of church and state right
yeah yep I believe that we can
absolutely see and fight when certain
ideological views based on religion try
to permeate in our government and
because our government was for the
longest time comprised
of people who were over well in
Christian it did pass through and over
time that's actually changed morality
laws have gone away you know clothing
laws have changed and that's because we
have this separation but this is not
this is not legally defined as a
religion because it's an ideology which
means it is leaking into our government
and it is now affecting our laws and
things make no sense anymore like the
multi gender thing all of a sudden now
in New York you can be literally any
gender you can make it up or a situation
you can be an animal yeah well
technically yes in New York they defined
gender identity as self-expression okay
yup that's it
because how else do you define it what
what's the difference between a you know
a woman who's gender-neutral who's got a
short haircut and is wearing like a
sleeveless you know black t-shirt and
jeans and a woman who is self-identified
as female knows nothing of any of this
stuff and is wearing the exact same
clothes the same haircut you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference right unless
they told you because they self-identify
so the log comes out so this is what you
end up getting when there's no
separation between the gooble gobble
people and in the government you end up
with the changing of words and
definitions which alter the laws
overnight well thankfully this video
isn't from like a government faction of
some sort yeah by just a bunch of people
showing up to but to show how but their
support in this way okay thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you